what makes a good podcast is a real
attention to narrative and writing and
trying to tell stories that haven't
already been told a lot of shows are
actually doing just radio plays
essentially their shows like the truth
that are actually doing radio fiction
it's like the shadow or welcome to night
Vale it's it's like 30s radio it's like
30 serialized radio and honestly and I
don't remember who coined the phrase but
the radio is the theater of the mind
it's like you can you know how they say
a picture's worth a thousand words well
a word is worth a million pictures if I
say tree you can visualize millions of
different trees so we give you these
stories we give you sound but you create
the world in your head and there's
something immensely satisfying about
that I mean you know roughly what we're
talking about but you much like reading
a book it's like you decide what the
characters look like you decide what the
hosts look like you decide what the in
what environment they're in where it's
being recorded what the subjects look
like what the world that the the subject
are describing looks like there's
something really there's a certain level
of imagination inspiring and control
that you get with radio that you don't
get with movies or other or 3d or any
other modern technology
you